[Music]
if you're new to the adventures of
wonder woman you might not be familiar
with the villain known as cheetah
but now that she's ready to hit the
silver screen there's no better time to
bone up on diana's feline arch nemesis
this is the untold truth of cheetah
barbara and minerva has been the main
cheater in the comics ever since the
1980s
and is easily the character's most
well-known alter ego
and she is also the character kristen
wiig plays in wonder woman 1984.
i don't want to be like anyone i want to
be an
apex predator but she wasn't the first
cheater
while minerva first appeared in 1987
another cheetah debuted in 1943
only a couple of years after wonder
woman herself that very first cheetah
was priscilla rich
she debuted in wonder woman volume 1
number 6 by the comics original creative
team of william marston
and harry g peter priscilla was the one
and only cheetah until 1980
when wonder woman vol 1 number 274
saw the mantle taken up by priscilla's
niece an environmental activist named
deborah domain
the dc continuity was rebooted in the
crisis on infinite earth's event in the
mid-1980s
leaving the door open for another new
cheetah in wonder woman volume 2
number 7. barbara and minerva herself a
man named sebastian balosteros
usurped minerva's powers and briefly
became the cheetah
in wonder woman volume 2 number 171
but barbara returned to the role before
long
given that wonder woman stands shoulder
to shoulder with superman and has been
known to fight greek gods from time to
time
you'd think her arch nemesis would be
comparably powerful
but priscilla rich the original cheetah
had no superpowers at all
in fact much like a certain other dc
character priscilla's primary as set is
her wealth
her villainous origin lies in the moment
when the woman steals the spotlight from
her at a charity event
making the hungarians intensely jealous
as any reasonable person would
priscilla responds to this unintentional
slight by putting on a cheetah skin
costume
and framing wonder woman for robbery
then trying to kill her
despite her relatively low power level
cheetah remained a thorn in wonder
woman's side throughout the 1940s
during one story she betrays her own
country by passing on military secrets
to the japanese during world war
ii in another priscilla infiltrates
paradise island
and steals queen hippolyta's magical
girdle of power enabling her to finally
go toe-to-toe with wonder woman herself
obviously she still loses which really
can't be good for the old self-esteem
one element of the cheetah character
that's been there since the very
beginning
is the notion of the feline persona as a
separate personality
cheetah's human alter ego whoever that
may be often struggles against and gives
in to the feral persona in their head
before priscilla rich starts wearing her
rug
a fully outfitted cheetah appears in a
vanity mirror encouraging the heiress to
give in to her hatred of wonder woman
and become the quote treacherous
relentless huntress
she already is on the inside decades
later debbie domain stepped into the
cheetah's furry shoes
debbie is a genuinely nice person and a
good friend to wonder woman
until she's brainwashed by the
international supervillain cobra
who transforms her into a vicious
huntress in her own right
for barbara and minerva the divide is
more mystical with the animal instinct
of the cheetah leading her down a path
of animalistic viciousness
that part of her finds repellent no
matter how much she might struggle
however
the cheetah within her always yearns to
be free
given her semi-feral nature it might
come as some surprise to find that
cheetah is actually something of a
joiner
priscilla rich for example is a founding
member of villainy incorporated
an all-female team formed to take
revenge on wonder woman
debuting in wonder woman volume 1 number
28 the team made several appearances
over the years hoping to find strength
in numbers against the powerful amazon
princess
naturally it never quite works out for
them in addition to initially being an
agent of cobra
debbie domain is later recruited by the
ultra humanite
into the secret society of supervillains
dc's premier villain team of the 1970s
and 80s
as a member of the secret society debbie
faces both the justice society and the
justice league
then you've got barbara and minerva who
was a founding member of the post-crisis
version of the injustice league which
debuted in the justice league of america
wedding special
she's part of the triumvirates that
leads the league alongside lex luthor
and the joker mirroring the much
celebrated dc
trinity of their respective arch enemies
cheetah has also been part of what might
be dc's most enduring super villain team
of all
the legion of doom but that team's first
appearance wasn't actually in a comic
book
in 1978 the children's cartoon series
super friends was retooled as challenge
of the super friends
bringing it closer to the comics it was
based on challenge expanded the show's
roster of heroes
and introduced a team of dc comics super
villains for them to square off against
each week
the legion of doom a creation of this
cartoon is brought together by lex
luthor in a flying saucer-esque swamp
lair
it is the purpose of the legion to align
our infamous forces
against the powers of good and defeat
them leaving us
the rulers of the world the priscilla
rich version of cheetah represents
wonder woman's rose gallery
alongside giganta another animal print
clad golden age villainess
cheetah's most memorable episode in the
series is the secret origins of the
super friends
in which the legionnaires travel back in
time to prevent their enemies from
becoming superheroes
cheetah disguises herself as an amazon
and competes in the contest to determine
who will become wonder woman
managing to defeat princess diana and
become wonder woman herself
her triumph is short-lived however as
the flash also travels back in time to
set things right
while there have technically been four
cheaters the honest truth is that there
are only two of real significance to the
comics
but it's still worth taking a moment to
find out more about the awesome
debbie domain is priscilla rich's niece
and heir to her fortune
ambivalent about her own wealth debbie
becomes an ecological activist and even
makes friends with wonder woman
after encountering the amazon at sea
unfortunately she's soon kidnapped by
agents of cobra and a regimen of torture
and brainwashing
turns her into an agent of evil she
never appeared in a wonder woman story
after her introduction
although she did turn up as a villain in
various other stories
published over the next few years
including crisis on infinite
earth the story that would ultimately
erase her from continuity
sebastian balasteros is an argentine
businessman
and lover of another wonder woman foe
the immortal sorceress cersei
in a 2001 storyline he is able to
convince
urz khataga the god who empowers cheetah
to take the cheetah's powers from
barbara and minerva
and give them to him instead sebastian
is ultimately no match for barbara and
however
unable to access the cheetah's powers
she instead steals the powers of one of
the furies of greek myth
and ultimately kills balosteros giving
his blood to urge kataga as an offering
in exchange for becoming cheater once
more
when barbara minerva was first
introduced in 1987 she was depicted as a
duplicitous woman
who feigns friendship with wonder woman
in an attempt to steal her magic lasso
when dc revised won the woman's
continuity in 2016
as part of dc rebirth however she was
made into a far more likable character
they also tied her origin more closely
to wonder womans
cementing them as fated arch nemesis in
the current continuity
barbara and minerva is a brilliant
archaeologist with an impressive
reputation
when an amazon princess shows up in the
u.s speaking what appears to be a
dialect of ancient greek
dr minerva has called on to help
translate thus barbara ann
actually teaches diana the english
language and the two become close
friends
unfortunately their friendship is doomed
from the beginning and minerva is soon
led down a very dark path indeed
just as wonder woman can trace the
origin of her powers to the gods and
goddesses of mount olympus her nemesis
is also empowered by an ancient deity
cheetah's powers come from an african
plant guard named erz kataga
and they're as much of a curse as they
are a blessing during her travels
barbara and minerva learns of a ritual
by which a human woman
can become a bride of ur's kataga thus
attaining great power
she attempts a ritual having learned
from her friendship with wonder woman
that god-given superpowers are a very
real thing
unfortunately what minerva doesn't take
into account is that ancient gods tend
to be narrow-minded and
kind of sexist so because she isn't a
virgin the god rejects her
and with her rejection comes a horrific
curse transforming barbara anne into a
beastial creature
who craves human flesh ultimately
barbara and minerva does gain great
power from earthgataga
despite the drawbacks her speed strength
agility
and vicious killer instincts make her a
formidable foe
even for someone like wonder woman in
reality barbara and minerva's
transformation is
ultimately the fault of another wonder
woman villain the business tycoon known
as veronica kale chao was introduced to
dc comics in 2003. in an effort to give
wonder woman her own lex luthor
since first appearing in wonder woman
volume 2 number 196
she's become one of wonder woman's
greatest foes kale is rich
successful extremely intelligent and
resents everything wonder woman stands
for
and there's veronica kale who sends
barbara and minerva on her expedition
to gain the powers of urs kataga hoping
that an empowered minerva might be able
to help kale find the wonder woman's
homeland of themyscira
wonder woman had previously promised to
help barbara anne if she ran into
trouble
but kale disrupts their lines of
communication and keeps wonder woman too
busy to check on her friend
until it's too late unaware of the
extent of kale's manipulation
cheetah blames wonder woman for her
transformation into a bloodthirsty beast
although barbara anne occasionally
regains her humanity over the years
and ultimately understands that veronica
chao is to blame for her predicament
she and wonder woman remain enemies in
the convoluted history of comic book
characters
it seems like everyone is hooked up with
everyone else and a prime example of
this is the fling between clark kent and
barbara and minerva
from the non-canon comic superman
american alien in this story not only
does the pre-soups clark kent have a
romantic trip
with barbara but she also helps him
establish his dual identity
the premise for this comic is that clark
kent wins a trip to the bahamas but his
plane crashes on the way
luckily he finds a way to bruce wayne's
yacht but the billionaire isn't there
naturally everyone assumes that clark is
bruce wayne and barbara ann
another guest on the yacht convinces him
to go along with it
clark and barbara open up quite a bit to
one another throughout the storyline
with clark even dancing around the idea
of sharing his true
alien origin with her eventually the
two-part waves with nothing more than
fond memories of one another
but it's still a fascinating look at two
characters who might have been
if you're discussing which dc comics
characters are the fastest of all
superman and the flash tend to be the
main focus
that feels like an oversimplification
cheetah's name rarely even comes up
but honestly it probably should during
the flash war comic storyline
longtime flash writer josh williamson
gave dc nation his list of the 10
fastest
dc characters the first three are all
versions of the flash
barry allen wally west and the reverse
flash superman comes in fourth naturally
in fifth place as the black racer a
swift moving and
inescapable incarnation of death and
sixth on the list
barbara and minerva the fleet-footed
cheetah that puts her ahead of wonder
woman
shazam and basically everybody else in
the dc universe
it also means she's almost as fast as
death itself which you have to imagine
is something barbara ann is pretty proud
of
empowered by a god and given the aspect
of the fastest animal on land
cheetah's speed really is no joke check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite dc characters are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and to
the bell so you don't miss a single one